bonjour à tous alors que hier ségolène
royal présenté en conseil des ministres
les principales propositions de sa
future loi sur la transition énergétique
les commissions du développement durable
et des affaires économiques du sénat ont
auditionné luc oursel le pdg d'areva
objectif de cette audition il ya
justement voir le point de vue du géant
du nucléaire français sur ce futur
projet de loi actuellement en
préparation mais aussi l'interrogé sur
le très mauvais pré rapport qui a été
rendu par la cour des comptes mois de
mai qui remettent en cause et bien les
choix d'organisation d'areva ses choix
économiques et notamment sur la question
de le p r finlandais tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition qui s'est tenue
hier après midi en salle médicis au
sénat d'abord c'est un grand plaisir de
participer à vos travaux
j'avais prévu une partie de mon
introduction liminaire sur le projet de
loi de transition énergétique sans son
pouvoir imaginer le projet de loi serait
aujourd'hui communiqué met donc je
présenterai un peu les messages que nous
nous avons fait passer au gouvernement
dans cette juste une précision si j'ai
bien compris c'est j bien d'une
communication
à l'heure actuelle et non le projet de
loi entend elle qui n'est pas passé en
conseil d'état ni au conseil économique
social et environnemental
donc ça ne peut pas être le projet de
loi c'est une communication normale aux
hawks alors j'ai un cheval et sur les
procédures si je travaillais repris le
gardien du temps alors si vous voulez
pour nous ce qui nous paraît très
important dans ce dans ce projet de loi
c'est là l'ambition confirmé de la
france d'une part de réduire sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
d'autre part de continuer à réduire les
émissions de carbone et ce alors que se
profile à l'horizon la conférence sur
l'énergie et le climat de l'an 2015
alors de ce point de vue là je crois que
le bilan que la france a présenté dans
le domaine électrique est un bilan
correct puisque vous savez que dans le
domaine de la production d'électricité
simplement nous avons grâce au nucléaire
grâce à l'hydroélectricité grâce aussi
aux renouvelables même s'il représente
encore un pourcentage limité
nous avons aujourd'hui le plus bas
niveau de production de co2 par
kilowattheure produit on est à 70
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure ce qui
nous met à peu près à un cinquième de la
moyenne européenne
un cinquième de la moyenne européenne et
si on prend le pays qui a le plus
développé l'énergie éolienne aujourd'hui
qui est le danemark
vous arrivez à des valeurs de co2 qui
sont à peu près 7 à 8 fois supérieure à
la nôtre
pourquoi parce que tout simplement quand
il n'y a pas de vent le danemark doit
faire appel à des la production d' usage
interne ou alors ce qui est clair de ce
point de vue là c'est je pense que ça
apparaît dans les éléments de la
communication c'est que on ne peut pas
réduire une stratégie bas carbone on ne
peut pas réduire une stratégie énergie
simplement un sujet électrique et qu'il
faut travailler et même si ce n'est pas
notre métier est vrai qu'il faut
travailler d'une part sur le bâtiment et
qui représentent le quart des émissions
de co2 et d'autre part sur les
transports qui représente 41 % des
émissions et qui aujourd'hui peut-être
en tout cas dans n'ont pas été très
présent dans les débats préliminaires
qui se sont tenues en 2013 sur ce sujet
alors notre notre préoccupation encore
une fois c'est que le débat soit bien un
débat global sur le sujet énergétique et
qui ne soit pas un débat simplement sur
le sujet électrique et à l'intérieur du
sujet électrique qui ne soit pas
simplement un débat pour ou contre le
nucléaire pour des raisons bien
évidentes
encore une fois dans le domaine de
l'électricité nous ne pouvons que nous
féliciter au niveau national des
résultats en matière de compétitivité du
prix de l'électricité en matière de
l'indépendant en matière d'indépendance
en matière de contributions la balance
commerciale et puis aussi évidemment en
matière d'émissions de co2 alors ce que
ce que nous pensons par rapport à cela
c'est que de ce point de vue là si un
des objectifs essentiels delà de la
stratégie énergétique c'est la réduction
des émissions de co2
eh bien on peut réfléchir à une
augmentation de la part de l'électricité
dans le mix énergétique globale puisque
aujourd'hui il est possible et il sera
encore possible demain de produire cette
électricité avec une un impact limité
alors ou doux comment pourrait se faire
cette ce développement de la part de
l'électricité dans le bilan énergétique
et bien tout simplement par le
développement toute une série de
nouveaux usages de l'électricité qui
sont les technologies de l'information
qui sont le développement des transports
urbains les villes intelligentes les
systèmes de la voiture électrique et
cetera toute nouvelle application qui se
traduiront vraisemblablement par une
augmentation de la consommation
d'électricité
même si en parallèle il faut continuer
toutes les actions de maîtrise des
consommations d'énergie et des
consommations d'électricité en
particulier
alors l'autre élément important aussi de
ce message c'est que tout c'est une
transformation majeure d'engager la
transition énergétique et que cela
nécessite de le faire de façon
progressive
je crois que l'un de vos collègues
sénateurs bizet a justement montrer le
coût et les inconvénients d'une démarche
qui se ferait à part ça pas forcé à
partir de l'exemple allemand
puisqu'on voit que l'exemple allemand a
coûté très cher en matière de
subventions renouvelables que les prix
de l'électricité en allemagne n'ont
cessé d'augmenter pour arriver
maintenant pour les ménages à un prix
qui est à peu près le double des prix
français
et puis avec il faut bien le dire aussi
peu de conséquences en termes
industriels puisque près de 30000
emplois ont été détruits en allemagne
aussi bien dans la filière des
industriels que je suis dans les
compagnies électriques
il est assez révélateur de noter qu'une
entreprise comme siemens pourtant
fleuron de cette transition énergétique
en allemagne a décidé d'abandonner toute
activité en donne du solaire voilà donc
je crois que c'est pour nous aussi un
rappel que une transition énergétique
c'est quelque chose qui doit le gérer
dans la durée de façon progressive et
avec autant que faire se peut la
nécessité de mettre en place une filière
industrielle et je crois que c'est ce
qui a été bien un bien montré alors le
concernant le nucléaire
je crois que pour nous le
l'objectif c'est évidemment d'engager
cette diversification tout en préservant
le patrimoine public que représente la
filière qui est aujourd'hui à peu près
la troisième filière industrielle
française
quand vous faites la somme de tous les
emplois qui sont aussi bien dans la
production que dans les entreprises qui
sont fournisseurs de cette de cette
activité est de ce point de vue là dans
le dans les réflexions gouvernementales
nous avons noté l'existence de la
demande que soit présenté un plan
stratégique régulièrement par edf alors
ce plan stratégique c'est pour nous un
outil extrêmement précieux parce qu'il
doit permettre justement on va d'abord
de confirmer l'engagement dans le
nucléaire et d'envoyer un message
extrêmement fort j'y reviendrai à tous
les pays qui veulent développer
l'énergie nucléaire et qui ont besoin
des compétences françaises
ce plan stratégique c'est aussi
l'opportunité d'assurer la cohérence du
développement entre nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables dans le domaine
électrique et ce plan stratégique très
important pour areva et j'y reviendrai
c'est qu'on parle bien entendu beaucoup
du parle de réacteurs il faut aussi
parler de l'approvisionnement de ses
réacteurs en combustible ainsi que de
retraitement je vous rappelle à ce titre
pour bien mesurer le lien qui existe
entre les deux entreprises que edf
représente 25% du chiffre d'affaires
d'areva et areva est de loin le premier
fournisseur d'edf dans l'ensemble des
achats avec le près de 10% des achats
donc il ya automatiquement une même
signe des entreprises sont différentes
même si elles ont des métiers différents
il ya automatiquement une logique
commune et une la nécessité d'avoir une
approche commune de ces de ces
différents sujets alors c'est
particulièrement vrai pour un domaine
qui le domaine du retraitement
puisque vous savez que c'est un choix
qui a été fait par la france ainsi que
d'autres pays de retraiter le
combustible usé et d'ivoire la meilleure
façon de gérer d'abord les ressources en
uranium
et puis ensuite gérer les déchets ça
représente aujourd'hui près de 6500
emplois entre si vous comptez laguë
melox c'est un leadership technologique
mondiale qui nous permet de proposer ces
technologies dans d'autres dans d'autres
marchés nous sommes en entrant trempe en
train de négocier avec la chine un
contrat très significatif pour la
construction d'une usine de retraitement
en chine alors vous le savez que de ce
point de vue là dans l'évolution du parc
de réacteurs au jeu
du à peu près plus d'une vingtaine de
réacteurs français utilisent du box donc
sur les 58 et il faut donc prévoir dans
les évolutions de ce parc si certains de
ces réacteurs sont amenés à fermer
il faut éléments prévoir dans le dans le
futur et dans la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs des réacteurs capable
d'utiliser ce ce mox alors où en
sommes-nous pour répondre à une de vos
questions sur les perspectives devant la
taille de tanger et bien elles sont
elles sont importantes et maintenant
très clairement 3 apprend fukushima
elles repartent
vous avez il se passe beaucoup de choses
en ce moment dans le domaine de
l'énergie
vous avez un phénomène qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'ils aient plusieurs
pays producteurs d'hydrocarbures
ça a été le cas des émirats arabes unis
c'est maintenant lequel l'arabie
saoudite du kazakhstan de la malaisie et
de l'indonésie envisage de développer le
nucléaire pour recours pour produire
pour couvrir leurs propres besoins de
d'électricité et je crois que le fait
que des pays qui détiennent des réserves
majeures dans le domaine dans le domaine
des hydrocarbures veut y avoir recours
au nucléaire c'est un signal que cette
énergie a un rôle à jouer dans le futur
nous avons beaucoup de prospects aussi
bien sûr en asie et en chine en
particulier où les besoins d'électricité
sont très importants et les besoins
d'une électricité propre sont encore
plus importants compte tenu des
contraintes très fortes qu'ils ont en ce
moment en matière de pollution et
d'environnement
et puis vous avez toute une série de
pays en europe qui envisagent un
développement de l'énergie nucléaire
alors on a parfois l'image que l'europe
pour que le nucléaire en europe ce
serait une énergie du passé il faut
savoir qu'il ya aujourd'hui 16 pays qui
ont utilisé des centrales nucléaires ou
on l'ambition d'en construire et que le
nucléaire représente de ce point de vue
à 30% des comptes de la production
d'électricité en europe
alors évidemment quelles sont ces pays
bas côté nous la grande bretagne qui
après avoir misé massivement sur les
ressources sur ses ressources en gaz se
rend compte de la nécessité de
rééquilibrer son mix énergétique et de
re développer le nucléaire il avait le
nucléaire aujourd'hui représentent 20 %
à peu près de la production
d'électricité en grande bretagne
et vous savez l'importance du projet que
nous avons avec edf de construire des op
r en grande bretagne grâce à une
nouvelle régulation du secteur
électrique
si ce projet est approuvé par bruxelles
d'ici la fin de l'année
je pense qu'ils en entraînera bien
d'autres et on peut penser à la pologne
où un certain nombre d'autres pays
d'europe centrale où il y aura des
projets de paix est donc ses
perspectives de ventes elles existent
avec le recteur rpr donc le plus gros
elle existe aussi avec le réacteur atmea
qui est un réacteur de 1000 mégawatts de
taille moyenne pour lequel nous avons
des négociations très active en turquie
pour 4 apnea et pour lequel nous avons
aussi des discussions au vietnam
aujourd'hui et demain au brésil alors il
est incontestable que ces deux réacteurs
bénéficie d'une part de la force de
l'équipe de france delà de toute
l'expérience à la fois de l'opérateur
edf et de l'industriel areva il
bénéficie aussi du retour d'expérience
des premiers projets de père que nous
sommes en train de construire certains
avec difficulté il faut pas le cacher et
il bénéficie aussi du fait que le label
france est reconnue comme un label
absolument essentiel en matière de
sûreté
grâce aussi à la coopération avec
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
alors le seul je crois que c'est un
point important aussi dire que nous
sommes convaincus qu'il ya la place pour
des renouvelables aux énergies
renouvelables areva s'est lancé dans le
domaine des renouvelables avec d'une
part la volonté de profiter de ce marché
qui se développe mais avec aussi
l'ambition de contribuer à régler un
problème qui est lié à ces énergies
renouvelables qui est aujourd'hui à part
quelques unes leur manque de
compétitivité et la nécessité de les
développer à coup de subventions comme
c'était le cas dans d'autres pays
donc notre ambition c'est de nous
positionner sur des domaines où notre
capacité technologique où notre
expérience de gestion des grands projets
doit permettre de réduire le coût de
développement de ces énergies alors
c'est particulièrement le cas l'éolien
offshore où vous savez que nous venons
droite pour remporter les deux derniers
appellent les 2 ap les deux champs lors
de l'appel d'offres lancé par le par le
gouvernement et dans ce domaine nous
sommes convaincus qu'il ya beaucoup de
possibilités en france en
grande-bretagne en allemagne et dans
bien d'autres pays est sans doute plus
tard en asie alors pour ce faire nous
pensons qu'il faut jouer d'ores et déjà
la carte de la consolidation européenne
et nous avons créé un partenariat avec
une entreprise espagnole gamesa pour
devenir demain un des leaders européens
de façon générale ce sera la stratégie
d'areva dans le renouvelable
ces deux systématiquement rechercher des
partenariats nationaux ou européens pour
développer ses énergies à la fois pour
partager les coûts de développement à la
fois pour partager les compétences
techniques et augmenter les chances
d'accès au marché
c'est ce que nous avons fait dans le
domaine du stockage de l'électricité
nous venons de créer une entreprise dans
le domaine de l'hydrogène avec une
société française qui s'appelle smart
energy et avec le soutien de l'ademe
alors ce stockage aujourd'hui nous
pensons que le stockage n'est pas assez
soutenu à titre d'exemple si vous êtes
un investisseur dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables
et si vous décidez d'installer une
capacité de stockage a coûté vous n'avez
pas de rémunération particulière pour
cette capacité de stockage et donc nous
pensons que ce projet de loi peut être
l'occasion de donner une prime à ceux
qui développe ses capacités de stockage
pour répondre à votre question quelle
technologie mais c'est justement une des
difficultés
il est encore trop tôt pour dire quelle
sera la technologie dominante sur ce
sujet d'ailleurs il n'aura probablement
pas une il y aura un ensemble de
technologies qui seront capables de
couvrir les besoins depuis les
technologies bien connus comme les
stations de pompage hydroélectrique
jusqu'au batterie et aux technologies
hydrogène
l'important pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
de pouvoir réaliser des démonstrateurs
de pouvoir les réaliser rapidement et à
partir de ces démonstrateurs de
clairement montré l'intérêt de ces
technologies de stockage
là aussi il est difficile d'imaginer que
seuls des initiatives nationales
pourront permettre de de ré est de créer
les champions auquel
que nous ambitionnons et qu'il faudra
chercher très vite des partenariats
européens avec des procédures
simplifiées
alors tous eu tout ce cadre général si
vous les faits que pour un groupe comme
areva cette transition énergétique c'est
une source d'opportunités parce qu'il ya
deux parce qu'il ya un gros travail à
faire en matière de construction de
nouveaux réacteurs
parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup à faire
sur les réacteurs existants qui
fonctionne dans le monde aujourd'hui
vous savez 85% du chiffre d'affaires
d'areva est essentiellement fait avec
les réacteurs existants qui consomment
des combustibles ou qui ou qui ont
besoin de retraitement ou qui ont besoin
d'activités de maintenance
et puis en parallèle ce développement
donc des renouvelables que j'évoquais
alors quelle quelle est la situation
d'areva
alors le pré rapport de la cour des
comptes vous me sourire mais pour nous
ça n'est pas vraiment une nouveauté
puisque ce rapport qui a été c'est un
prérapport de bon qui n'a pas fait
l'objet encore de toutes les
contradictions
ce pré rapport décrit la période 2006
je ne peux à titre en tant que
responsable de cette entreprise que
regrettait qu' un tel rapport n'a
intervienne si tard c'est voler il eût
été préférable que la période 2006-2011
2006 2012 soit traité en 2012
ce rapport décrit en particulier ce que
nous avions très clairement mis en
évidence lorsque la nouvelle équipe
s'est mise en place c'est qu'il ya eu
une dégradation de la situation
financière d'areva entre 2006 et 2011
qui n'était pas acceptable qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas se prolonger
et que à partir de 2011 nous avons pris
toute une série de mesures pour
redresser l'entreprise et en particulier
avec l'objectif de diminuer sa dette
alors pour je pourrai répondre de façon
plus précise aux mesures d elles sont
classiques beaucoup de mesures dans le
domaine de la de la croissance d'abord
essayé de rechercher systématiquement
les champs de croissance réduire nos
coûts 1 milliard d'économies à l'horizon
de 2015 céder un certain nombre
d'activités qui n'était pas essentielle
ou des participations qui n'était pas
essentiel ce que nous avons fait et puis
ramener l'entreprise à l'équilibré
financier pour la première fois en 2013
depuis 2005 les nous avons atteint
l'équilibré de trésorerie opérationnel
c'est-à-dire que nous avons pu financer
100% de nos investissements
autant de cash est rentré que de cacher
est sorti mais il ya encore du jeu
à faire pour que nos pulsions diminuer
l'endettement de l'entreprise qui
restent qui restent trop élevés
et alors dans la situation actuelle du
marché nucléaire sous les n'est pas
dramatique parce que le marché à court
terme duclair reste incertain mais il
est nécessaire que l'entreprise puisse
avoir les capacités de saisir des
opportunités éventuelles d'acquisition
qui se présenteraient dans le nucléaire
ou dans le domaine des renouvelables
et puis être capable s'il lorsque le
marché repartira de réaliser les
investissements importants qui seront
nécessaires pour accompagner le
développement de ce marché dans le
domaine des énergies renouvelables
donc encore une fois nous allons
continuer les partenariats aujourd'hui
nous avons choisi plusieurs secteurs le
l'éolien offshore nous avons choisi le
solaire à concentration
nous avons choisi la biomasse et nous
avons choisi de stockage d'énergie
nous ne sommes pas malheureusement ce
nid sur l'éolien terrestre ni sur le
photovoltaïque qui sont des marchés il
faut bien le dire déjà bien occupé il
est certain que le je pense qu'on peut
dire sans critique que nous avons raté
ce virage des renouvelables et d'éolien
terrestre et du photovoltaïque etc
aujourd'hui le marché est
particulièrement occupés par des
constructeurs non européens ont peu l'on
peut quelques-uns européen dans le
domaine de l'éolien terrestre mais dans
le domaine du photovoltaïque massivement
des concurrents asiatiques etc
aujourd'hui sauf à réaliser des
acquisitions massives
il est difficile de revenir sur ces
différents sujets mais les technologies
sur lesquelles nous sommes
représenteront à notre sens une quantité
significative de développement des
renouvelables
voilà très rapidement propos introductif
et je préfère laisser le temps aux
questions pour la suite
non merci alors monsieur courteau
d'abord oui merci monsieur le président
concernant les énergies renouvelables
vous avez évoqué les stands derrière la
demande du président raoul l'éolien
offshore j'y suis effectivement
favorable je m'interroge sur l'éolien
offshore en méditerranée
est-ce que la solution compte tenu des
grandes formes et des épaisseurs de
sédiments
notamment dans le golfe du lion mais un
petit peu partout d'ailleurs est-ce que
la solution la seule passerez par
l'éolien offshore mais flou total
vous avez évoqué la biomasse s'agit-il
de recherche sur les biocarburants et
notamment de deuxième et troisième
génération nous aimerions que vous en
ayez un petit peu plus là dessus
deuxième question que se passe-t-il avec
le père de fernande pouvez vous nous en
dire plus sur certaines difficultés que
l'on rencontrerait actuellement
et avez-vous des remarques à faire sur
l'objectif de réduire de 50% la part du
nucléaire en france dans le bouquet
énergétique un horizon proche et enfin
une question plus locale qui concerne la
filière nucléaire
je souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
réalisation de comurhex 2 sur les deux
sites de pierrelatte et de narbonne
on me signale que l'on rencontrerait des
problèmes d'ordre financier concernant
leurs réalisations et je m'interroge
également sous le problème de production
à la baisse qui en résulterait la
crainte est temps que les deux sites
soit me d'après ce que j'entends dire à
l'arrêt de production durant un certain
temps
qu'en est il exactement et enfin
concernant le stockage de l'électricité
vous avez évoqué une installation
existante déjà
s'agit-il de celles qui fonctionnent en
corse et pouvez vous nous en dire plus
sur sa capacité actuelle
et peut-on considérer que cette
technologie est fiable viable vous donne
satisfaction et envisagez vous de passer
au stade d'un développement plus
conséquent bien l'opération corse et
bien mire avec le ca s'est mis tout le
monde on m'avait échappé au joli nom
non mais rien ne m'échappe monsieur copé
monsieur fiel merci monsieur le
président
lui je voulais poser de question en fait
moi je me réjouis d'expansion extérieur
d'arriva évidemment une grande
entreprise emblématique notre pays
mais je voulais vous poser quand même
une première question concernant les
centrales que vous vendez dans des pays
émergents dans les zones dans des zones
géopolitiques sensible comment vous
assurez vous de la sûreté nucléaire dans
ces pays de la maintenance dans la durée
puisque une centrale nucléaire
aujourd'hui on le voit en france et 40
ans donc c'est quand même un sujet
important
deuxième question sur un peu un peu
général aussi mais moi qui m'intéresse
beaucoup dans le cadre de la
restructuration industrielle de notre
pays
le gars le rapport gallo a montré que
beaucoup de choses en particulier un
problème spécifiquement français les
grandes entreprises françaises sur le
marché international travaillent seuls
les allemands pour prendre cet exemple
là embarque avec un avec les entreprises
allemandes embarque avec elle des sous
traitants allemand de telle sorte qu'il
y ait dans la filière et les filières
proches
une dynamique qui est tout à fait
positive pour le l'industrie allemande
qu'en est-il d'arriva sur les marchés
internationaux
merci d'être des sujets d'actualité
peut-être un peu chaud ils affluent à
refroidir le réacteur
je pense je vais peut-être laissé les
paroles tout de suite à monsieur foucher
mais la question de monsieur filleul
évidemment me brûle lève dans le
contexte actuel est depuis lundi soir
depuis donc rite lundi soir l'opération
alstom
évidemment et en particulier est ce que
ceci a des conséquences pour areva quels
sont vos partenariats privilégiés
vous n'êtes pas obligé de tout dire il
vous sera beaucoup pardonné un monsieur
foucher monsieur le président merci
simplement c'est sûr que nous sommes
fiers de ce dont ce pays d'avoir deux
entreprises comme areva comme edf
naturel monde qui sont au top niveau
pour poser de questions notre ami roland
courteau a évoqué le stockage et je peux
nous dire quelles sont les perspectives
de stockage quand les voyez vous
finalisez je veux dire pour qu'elle soit
efficace et deuxièmement dans un article
des échos du 13 juin
j'ai lu que le gouvernement d'angela
merkel a décidé de stopper les garanties
de crédit à l'exportation de composants
nucléaires
le ministre de l'économie allemand
sigmar gabriel indiquant que l'allemagne
abandonner l'énergie nucléaire car elle
implique des risques considérables et
non maîtrise a pour toi c'est la version
des allemands mais cette décision aurait
été prise ce lens qui ne sont nous
disait avec les ministères des affaires
étrangères des finances et du
développement des différents pays de
l'europe
donc je crois que paris s'inquiète d'un
mauvais signal envoyé à l'industrie quel
est aujourd'hui votre réaction
monsieur le président sur la position à
le monde que des questions faciles
monsieur le président à vous voyez bien
les normes et je crains qu'on monte en
puissance
monsieur vaugrenard si monsieur le
président
on disait dans ma jeunesse il faut
promettre que ce qu'on peut tenir
est-ce que vous pensez que la promesse
et crédible qui consiste à dire qu'on
peut réduire le nucléaire de 75 à 50% en
si peu de temps
donc ces questions d'ordre général et
ensuite est-ce qu areva compte investir
dans l'hydrolienne et si c'est le cas ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut passer
rapidement de l'expérimentation à
l'opérationnel une source d'énergie
particulièrement intéressante parce qu
elle al'avantage d'être permanente ce
qui est pas le cas de l'éolien donc
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue sur
cette question là nous avons 10 youn et
monsieur bigot administrateur général du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et un
moment été évoquée
l'évolution du traitement des déchets et
leur éventuelle réutilisation comme
source d'énergie et l'esc areva
travaille sur cette question là et quel
potentiel
peut se dégager nous semble
particulièrement intéressant quels
partenariats également areva a déjà ou
compte à voir avec d'autres partenaires
d'autres partenaires importants au
niveau du continent européen de l'union
européenne et enfin dernière question
par rapport au gaz de schiste est ce
qu'il existe de votre côté de la
recherche fondamentale permettant
d'éviter d'utiliser le gall 2 6 par la
manière traditionnelle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui parfois que fracturation
yannick vaugrenard
juste une petite précision par rapport à
tes questions il s'agit tu veux évoquer
la méta nation ou sur les déchets c'est
quoi le mettre en situation
monsieur be good year la possibilité de
réutiliser à l'ordre de réutiliser ce
que j'ai compris à moi je suis pro
physicien loin s'en faut de réutiliser
les déchets
nucléaire nucléaire pour être à nouveau
source d'énergie en armes et je croyais
que monsieur vaugrenard chevauchée sur
le domaine privilégié de madame didier
je me serais pas permis
madame didier jeunes merci président
monsieur le président la première
question porte sur le développement du
nucléaire
est-ce que areva se donnent des limites
quant au développement du nucléaire dans
certains pays je pense par exemple les
pays à forte activité sismique à risque
de tsunami ou des pays instables
politiquement
est-ce que vous avez une politique dans
ce sens là la deuxième question porte
sur la santé des populations autour des
de l'extraction des mines d'uranium
on sait qu'aujourd'hui la question a été
posée que pouvez-vous nous dire sur ce
sujet troisième question développez-vous
l'activité de démantèlement et si oui
comment
4 est ce que pour équilibrer votre
activité vous avez besoin de créer sans
cesse de nouvelles unités au fond est ce
que l équilibre de d'areva est dépendant
directement de la création de nouvelles
centrales au quel cas combien
installeront nous dans le monde de
centrales en augmentant potentiellement
les risques de nouveaux fukushima je
veux dire qu'à un moment donné peut-être
qu'on va pas couvrir le monde entier de
centrales nucléaires est ce qu'à un
moment donné on s'arrête cinquième
question la question de la sécurité qui
n'a pas été abordé mais qui est au coeur
du refus de certaines personnes ou de
certains pays ou de secours d'un groupe
politique de l'énergie nucléaire
c'est très clair donc voilà où en est on
on sait pertinemment que lorsqu'on
cherche à faire de la productivité
il y a les deux sujets sur lesquels
systématiquement on fait de la
productivité c'est à la fois la masse
salariale et sur les questions de
sécurité c'est traditionnel dans les
autres industries
comment voyez vous cette question et
dernière question bur
bur qu'en est il
on sait que on est aujourd'hui à la fin
d'une enquête publique qui n'a pas été
forcément un modèle et qui est pourtant
au coeur de la démarche de ce type
d'installation de projets et donc
comment allez-vous terminer cette
question même si vous n'êtes pas
forcément directement à la manoeuvre
ticulier les questions que vous évoquez
de vendre des centrales nucléaires un
des pays alors vous parlez de stabilité
géologique mais on peut avoir politique
comme vous l'évoquez est-ce que la
condition nécessaire
ce serait pas qu' au moins une autorité
de sûreté internationales concernant le
nucléaire
una scène internationale avant de passer
le contrat parce que oui c'est ça bien
monsieur le président a bien cette salle
je les compétitions et défend je prends
les questions dans l'ordre chronologique
alors éolien offshore en particulier en
méditerranée au lien flottants c'est
incontestable que l'éolien offshore que
nous développons aujourd'hui nécessite
des fonds relativement peu profond on va
aller facilement jusqu'à 40 50 mètres et
ils font des fonds effectivement qu'ils
aient une certaine qualité d'où nous
n'avons pas ça partout
évidemment sur les côtes françaises mais
aussi à l'étranger vous avez un très bon
exemple avec le japon qui a tout de
suite dé fond extrêmement profond donc
il ya effectivement des premiers travaux
qui commencent pour le développement des
liens flottant qui sont pour l'instant
les travaux de recherche et de
développement et nous avons nous en tant
qu areva décidé de soutenir une start up
française qui porte le joli nom de
nénuphars et donc c'est un projet que
nous soutenons aussi avec la
participation des pouvoirs publics avec
l'objectif de développer un
démonstrateur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est difficile
de tirer des plans très à très long
terme tant que nous n'avons pas mis au
point un démonstrateur mai
si vous voulez technologiquement cela
pose un certain nombre de problèmes ce
que j'espère personnellement c'est une
forte coopération avec l'industrie
pétrolière qui peut nous apprendre
beaucoup si vous voulez sur la gestion
de plates formes complexes en mer leur
stabilisation en particulier alors quand
je parle de biomasse non je ne parle pas
de biocarburants qui sont ils ne sont
pas le scope de travail d'areva je parle
vraiment du développement la production
d'électricité à partir de la biomasse
donc nous avons par exemple une
opération qui fonctionne à pierrelatte
nous avons aussi développé une centrale
de production d'électricité aux pays bas
donc ça c'est une activité production
donc électricité et chaleur
la difficulté que nous rencontrons sur
toute une série de projets n'est pas un
problème technique
c'est un problème de ressources et l'on
revient toujours à la même problématique
de la ressource en bois et en déchets
bois si vous voulez pour pouvoir
alimenter de façon stable et dans des
conditions économiques et dans des
conditions économiques
le ces installations alors pour pour
jeunes éléments mais il ya alors disent
que ce que nous essayons de faire pour
contribuer à résoudre ces problématiques
de l'arceau c'est de développer des
technologies de torréfaction ou en fait
on utilise des roses des des bois et
végétaux de différentes origines avec
l'année c'est avec l'objectif de
fabriquer ce que nous avons appelé le
charbon vert c'est-à-dire des finalement
des pastilles si vous voulez qu'ils
seraient plus homogène - moins lourde
puisque de seiche
donc moi moins pesant tu es plus
économique à transporter donc nous avons
une installation de torréfaction des
monstres action qui commence à
fonctionner dans le nord de la france et
qui peut être une façon une façon une
contribution à la résolution de ces
problèmes de ressources alors le père
finlandais
quels sont les quel est le point de la
situation c'est un projet qui très
clairement était le premier n'était pas
effectuée sur le territoire national
dont qui a incontestablement accumulé
quelques difficultés au démarrage
aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui est
terminé à près de 87% et donc nous
arrivons maintenant progressivement vers
la phase d'essai
nous avons franchi en ce début d'année
des étapes importantes avec d'abord la
réalisation du test de confinement de
l'enceinte qui est une étape très
importante pour vérifier la la
robustesse
nous avons eu aussi l'approbation de
l'autorité de sûreté finlandaise pour le
contrôle-commande savais que c'était un
sujet qui était latent depuis un certain
temps et donc il faut retenir qu
aujourd'hui les problèmes de le p r
finlandais qui sont des problèmes très
lourd financièrement pour arriva ne sont
pas des problèmes techniques il n'y a
pas de problème technique en finlande il
ya un problème essentiellement
contractuel il ya un problème de
relations commerciales très difficile
avec le client qui se traduit par un
contentieux très très lourd puisque nous
avons lancé une procédure d'arbitrage
international et que nous demandons aux
clients 2 7 milliards d'euros
d'indemnisations
donc ça vous donne une idée de la
difficulté
nous avons un client qui n'arrive pas à
prendre ses responsabilités
alors que la phase d'essai s'approche et
qu'il faut absolument qu'ils prennent
maintenant les commandes
bon j'espère que les premières décisions
du tribunal arbitral sont attendus pour
le début de l'année 2015 et j'espère que
ces décisions influenceront positivement
le comportement du client pour que nous
arrivions à un démarrage satisfaisant de
frôler alors le client pour autant et
l'autorité de sûreté finlandaise et
c'est très important reconnaissent que
c'est la meilleure technologie
aujourd'hui disponible en particulier en
termes de sûreté à l'autorité de sûreté
finlandaise est très exigeante et donc
vraiment moi je souhaite qu'on retienne
il n'y a pas de problème technique en
finlande et un problème contractuel
l'objectif de réduire à 50%
je crois que si vous voulez parce que ce
que je retiens des dés d'abord c'est une
décision pour nous de nature
gouvernementale la politique énergétique
le choix du mix c'est pas une décision
laissée aux marchés c'est une
c'est un choix de souveraineté et en
tant qu'entreprise publique mais nous
nous travaillerons dans le cadre de ces
de ses objectifs ce que je retiens de la
rive de du projet du gouvernement c'est
une approche
pragmatiques à la fois qui consiste à se
baser sur un objectif
et puis à mettre en place des outils de
pilotage qui permettront d'ajuster 7
cette évolution au mieux des intérêts du
pays des consommateurs et de et de
l'entreprise il est évident qu'un des
paramètres essentiels de cette évolution
se sera l'évolution des consommations
d'électricité évolution des
consommations d'électricité liée à la
croissance économique la démographie
l'augmentation des usages et ses new
skies est très important comme je
l'évoquais c'est qu'il y ait une
continuité c'est à dire que non
seulement on raisonne à l'horizon 2025
mais que nous soit indiqué très
clairement la perspective
au delà de 2025 quelle sera la quelle
part qu'elle parle donc le nucléaire
joue puisque beaucoup de nos
investissements beaucoup de nos
programmes visent des horizons
évidemment beaucoup plus lointains alors
comme comurhex deux donc c'est une
installation qui en fait tu participes
qui est une modernisation de nos
installations existantes pour réaliser
la conversion qui est une des étapes de
fabrication du combustible
alors ce projet a été un projet très
ambitieux c'est un investissement très
important de près d'un milliard d'euros
sur le territoire français et c'est un
projet qui avait pour but de remettre au
niveau des installations qui étaient
assez ancien quelles sont les
difficultés actuelles devaient d'abord
le marché de la conversion est un marché
qui est très très difficile
il ya des surcapacités mondiales le fait
que les japonais n'est pas redémarré
amplifie ses surcapacités
le projet lui-même a connu quelques
difficultés de réalisation mais il faut
dire que nous avons mis la barre très
haut en matière d'évolutions
technologiques et d'évaluation et
d'évolution en matière de sûreté est
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas vraiment
de problèmes financiers au sens un
capacité de financer il y a
il y a un problème de bon déroulement de
ce projet nous avons donc pour éviter
une discontinuité de production nous
avons fait la demande à l'autorité de
sûreté de pouvoir prolonger la durée de
vie de l'installation comurhex 1 et donc
d'assurer comme ça une meilleure
transition entre l'installation de
conteneurs explique un qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui sur les deux sites et
l'installation de comurhex ii qui
fonctionnera demain et nous attendons
donc la position de l'autorité de sûreté
nous sommes prêts à faire quelques
investissements pour permettre cette
extension de durée de vie alors je
connais la préoccupation légitime des
équipes qui sont employés sur ce sur ce
site mais nous ferons tout pour avoir la
transition la plus correcte possible
entre comurhex un écho mx 2 en espérant
que l'autorité de sûreté nous donnera
cette extension de durée de vie alors
sur le stockage d'électricité
effectivement nous avons une opération
qui est un démonstrateur et ça dit bien
ce que ça veut dire en corse où nous
avons pour l'université d'ajaccio
combiné des installations
photovoltaïques avec des installations
de stockage ce qui permet tout
simplement de charger le stockage
pendant la journée et d'utiliser
l'énergie stockée pendant la nuit alors
pour une université évidemment les
consommations nocturne ne sont pas
énormes mais elles sont là c'est une
installation qui fonctionne avec
plusieurs centaines de kilowatts
donc c'est quand même une taille
significative en matière de
l'installation
aujourd'hui elle est surtout là pour
démontrer le concept technique
nous ne sommes pas encore en état de
démontrer si vous voulez l'intérêt
économique mais il faut à tout prix
faire simple il faut à tout prix faire
ce genre d'opération toutes ces
opérations renouvelables je le disais
dans mon propos liminaire il est
absolument impératif que nous puissions
faire rapidement des démonstrateurs ce
qui peut supposer des financements est
ce qui peut supposer aussi des
procédures allégées
si pour réaliser un démonstrateur il ya
il ya besoin de beaucoup de temps c'est
un problème alors sur les sur
l'expansion et extérieure et sur notre
politique de vente de centrales à
l'extérieur alors d'abord il est
extrêmement clair que toutes les toute
notre activité de promotion de centrales
nucléaires à l'extérieur se fait dans le
cadre des réglementations
internationales et dans le cadre
d'accords d'accords intergouvernementaux
entre la france et le et le pays
miao areva edf n'ont pas les moyens de
travailler dans des pays qui ne sont pas
agréés par le évidemment le gouvernement
français alors quelles sont nos quelles
sont nos exigences bien entendu d'abord
que ces pays acceptent l'ensemble des
régulations internationales dans le
domaine du nucléaire c'est absolument
évident que ces pays mettent en place
des autorités de sûreté ce qui veut pas
dire alors et là il ya un aspect très
important c'est la coopération a
développé à renforcer
entre les autorités de sûreté existantes
comme sous l'autorité de sûreté
française et ses nouvelles autorités de
sûreté moi j'aspire à ce que le très
clairement dans la mission de l'asn ils
apparaissent un rôle alors laquelle il
ya bien sûr mais qui est un qui a plus
un rôle de supervision générale mais
j'aspire à ce que dans la mission de
l'asn soient clairement explicitées une
mission de coopération internationale
justement avec les pays qui sont
demandeurs de ces de cette coopération
alors vous avez évoqué le problème de
maintenance dans la durée moi je crois
que de plus en plus cp les pays neufs
comme neuf au nucléaire j'entends comme
par exemple la turquie l'arabie saoudite
ou la pologne demain demande non
seulement la construction d'une centrale
mais elle demande aussi la présence d'un
exploitant de quelqu'un qui va aider et
le de là toute l'importance d'avoir une
très forte alliance entre areva et edf
pour par exemple aller sur les marchés
séoudiens ou polonais ou areva et gdf
suez pour aller sur les marchés tube
parce que c'est la présence de cet
exploitant durable dans les projets qui
permettra de garantir le bon le bon
fonctionnement de ces projets alors de
ce point de vue là je crois que là la
critique du rapport de louis gallois sur
les entreprises travaillant seul je
pense très honnêtement toute objectivité
qu'elle ne s'applique pas au nucléaire
parce que la filière est déjà très bien
organisés et lorsque nous allons à
l'étranger nous menons avec nous
plusieurs dizaines de pme et nous les
aidons même à s'installer ça a été le
cas en chine ou avec l'edf nos actions
ont permis aux pme françaises de
s'installer de durablement et de
participer au programme chinois
donc ça marche je crois que ça marche
bien c'est facilitée par le fait que
lorsque nous qualifions un fournisseur
c'est parce qu'il est il satisfait nos
exigences en matière de sûreté et que
pour requalifier un autre fournisseur ça
prendra énormément de temps donc le
partenaire
la pme est un partenaire naturel pour
autant de plus en plus de pays demandent
et on peut comprendre cette
préoccupation une augmentation de la
localisation de la fabrication locale
et là il appartient à nos partenaires à
nos pme de travailler
avait de trouver des partenaires locaux
de crédit joint-venture de signer les
accords de coopération et d'inventer de
nouvelles formes alors alstom pour nous
de ce point de vue ab alstom c'est un
partenaire évidemment très important si
vous prenez les quatre paires en
construction et les deux ep air
susceptibles d'être construit en grande
bretagne dans cinq cas sur six la
turbine a été fourni par alstom et donc
ça devient la référence commerciale
il est absolument indispensable que quel
que soit le repreneur
quelle que soit la solution industrielle
nous ayons nous la garantie de pouvoir
continuer à travailler avec ce
fournisseur de turbines qui est
absolument essentiel c'est la seule
préoccupation est l'expression du groupe
areva qui n'est pas impliquée après dans
la recherche ou dans quelques
négociations que ce soit alors sur le
stockage qu'elle finalisation peut être
à jeun suffisant c'est un sujet où moi
je suis convaincu qu'il y avait il ya
des possibilités
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
pour choisir la bonne solution il est
vraiment objectivement difficile
d'indiquer une date à partir de laquelle
ces technologies pourraient être
développée à grande échelle
ça doit être une priorité et pour moi ça
doit être une priorité européenne et
c'est le bon moment pour ce faire il est
beaucoup plus facile de faire des
alliances lorsqu'on est au démarrage des
travaux la première activité d arrêt dès
lors que lorsque chacun a déjà établi
son organisation industrielle alors vous
l'avez effectivement signalé madame
merkel a indiqué que la coface allemande
un hermès n'apporterait plus sa garantie
de crédit alors non pas pour la
fourniture de composants mais pour la
construction de nouvelles centrales
c'est à dire que nous avons nos équipes
allemandes par exemple on a un rôle
important pour vendre des composants
dans le domaine de la sûreté ça sera
toujours couvert mais par contre les
nouvelles centrales ne seront pas ne
seront pas soutenu par hermès alors
d'avoir ça pose un problème très clair
qui est un problème général qui est un
problème de financement de nos activités
export le dispositif français de
financement de soutien à l'export des
grandes infrastructures est un peu a
perdu de sa compétitivité par rapport à
nos gros concurrents et là il ya une
réflexion d'ensemble à avoir ça ne
concerne pas que le nucléaire
mais notre système est aujourd'hui qui
est un système indirects vous savez au
travers de
la coface qui intervient vis-à-vis des
partenaires financiers est un système
qui est plus coûteux que les systèmes de
financement direct qui ont été mis en
place dans les différents pays sion
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
l'allemagne bien entendu ça ne va pas
renforcer
ni le secteur nucléaire en allemagne les
pme nucléaires en allemagne ni nos
propres nous mêmes pour nos équipes
allemandes ça nous amène à nous poser un
certain nombre de questions sur leur
développement
alors une question sur sur l'hydrolienne
alors l'hydrolienne donc la production
d'électricité à partir de deux courants
marins là areva ne peut pas tout faire
non peu de compétences sous marine
d'autres entreprises françaises en ont
beaucoup plus et donc nous laissons à
ces entreprises comme comme dcns ou
d'autres le développement de ces
secteurs
mais voilà mais le mellah là aussi je
pense que toujours la même problématique
des démonstrateurs montré que la
technologie marche montrer la tester et
c'est seulement à partir de cette étape
que vous pouvez avoir une vision plus
prospective alors dans le domaine du
nucléaire le choix français pour la
partie des chais ces deux retraités les
combustibles déjà usé parce que c'est
intéressant économiquement et parce que
ça simplifie la gestion après des
déchets dans l'eure dans leur phase
finale c'est très il est le président de
la république avait confirmé que leur
traitement faisait partie des choix
français c'est très important pour nous
de pouvoir continuer cette activité est
bien entendu les choix qui seront faits
sur le parc nucléaire français sont de
ce point de vue là assez déterminant
puisque aujourd'hui sur la soixantaine
de réacteurs en france
vous en avez une vingtaine qui utilisent
le combustible mox donc il est
nécessaire dans la durée de garantir un
débouché pour ses activités sur les sur
les partenariats je les dis d'abord le
nucléaire pour nous c'est déjà un métier
de partenariat il ya beaucoup
d'activités domaine minier dans le
domaine technologique dans pour le
développement de nouveaux réacteurs
comme le réacteur atmea où nous avons
des partenaires qu'ils soient asiatiques
qu'il soit européen
ça ça fait partie de la logique pour le
renouvelable c'est une nouveauté mais ça
nous paraît une condition absolument
indispensable et nous cherchons tous les
partenaires qui peuvent nous apporter ou
des capacités technologiques
supplémentaires
où l'accès à certains marchés et des
modes de financement une grande grande
ouverture
ça peut être en france comme je vous le
cas que l'exemple que je vous ai donné
avec nos activités en domaine de
l'hydrogène mais ça peut être aussi en
europe comme le cas que je vous ai donné
avec l'éolien offshore sur le gaz de
schiste pas d'activités d'areva dans la
dans ce domaine pas de pas de
compétences particulières
alors encore une fois sur le
développement du nucléaire pour répondre
aux questions je crois que les limites
on ya les limites bien entendu ce sont
celles à l'acceptation par les pays où
nous travaillons de toutes les
réglementations internationales dans le
domaine du nucléaire c'est l'existence
d'autorités de sûreté réelle et efficace
et puis évidemment c'est la prise en
compte des risques particuliers mais qui
font l'objet comme par exemple les
risques sismiques qui font l'objet
d'études au cas par cas en turquie où
nous travaillons actuellement comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer il ya une très grande
attention à la compréhension de la
sismicité duciste et la possibilité il y
a des réponses technologiques
je vous rappelle que ce qui s'est passé
au japon les centrales ont résisté au
tremblement terre les problèmes du japon
ne sont pas liés aux tremblements de
terre les problèmes du japon sont liés
aux tsunamis qui est intervenue après il
est bon mais le tsunami n'y en a pas
dans toutes les zones où il ya des êtres
ambiante
vous avez des technologies aujourd'hui
qui sont des technologies d'ailleurs
largement diffusée aussi au japon en
termes sur la construction aussi bien
résidentiel que industriel qui permette
dont le principe est en fait de
déconnecter si j'ose dire l'installation
de du sol et donc d'éviter la
propagation des secousses vous avez
aussi évidemment des très nombreux
calculs de ce point de vue là le fait qu
août en turquie par exemple nous
travaillons avec l'entreprise japonaise
mitsubishi
c'est un élément qui permet vraiment de
mettre en commun toutes ces toutes ces
mesures pour protéger les installations
d'un point de vue sismique
alors la santé des populations autour
des autour des mines
bon c'est un sujet sous les nous dans le
domaine minier nous quand nous arrivons
dans un pays nous arrivons pour
longtemps et nous sommes là pour rester
et nous l'avons montré récemment avec
les accords que nous avons signés au
niger
si nous ne prenons pas en compte ces
questions de santé des populations
autour des mines nous ne resterions pas
nous ne saurions pas accepter dans la
durée ça fait partie si vous voulez des
choix absolument fondamentaux des
valeurs fondamentales avec lesquels le
groupe areva veut opérer et pratiquement
ça se passe comment bon bien entendu ça
se passe d'abord par un aspect très
important
nous appliquons partout en matière de
protection des travailleurs les mêmes
exigences en matière de radioprotection
par exemple même si la régulation
nationales parfois et plus lâches nous
appliquons systématiquement le niveau le
plus exigeant dans tous les pays du
monde
et deuxièmement nous avons mis en place
soit auprès des mines actuel soit
parfois auprès des mines qui ont été
fermées des observatoires de la santé
qui sont des dispositifs où nous
impliquons toutes les parties prenantes
locales
le système de santé pour assurer un
suivi des populations des populations
qui ont travaillé chez nous dans le
passé des populations actuelles de
l'environnement et jusqu'à présent ces
systèmes n'ont pas mis en évidence de
problème particulier
alors le démantèlement le démantèlement
aujourd'hui pour nous c'est déjà une
activité industrielle
ça n'est pas un marché futur c'est déjà
une activité industrielle parce que nous
démantelons nos propres installations
nous avons des installations par exemple
à la hague qui ont atteint une certaine
ancienneté donc nous avons acquis une
expérience et des compétences
mais c'est aussi une activité
commerciale puisque nous démentons des
activités du ca
nous avons aussi une expérience en
allemagne aux états-unis en travaillant
sur les installations du department of
energy department of defense
nous avons démantelé des centrales en
allemagne aux états unis et donc pour
nous si vous voulez ne s'agit pas d'une
nouvelle activité
quelle est la compétence d'areva en la
matière elle est d'abord dans le
diagnostic initial dans l'élaboration
des plans de démantèlement dans
l'évaluation des coûts pour lesquelles
nous sommes capables de proposer des
chiffres assez fiable et puis après dans
l'intervention dans les zones les plus
contaminées où nous avons l'habitude
d'évoluer avec des équipements
particuliers et avec l'expérience de nos
personnels c'est un marché donc qui
aujourd'hui représente déjà pour areva
entre 4 et 500 millions d'euros par an
vous voyez une quelque chose de
significatif
que nous ne voyons pas pour autant se
développer à très vive allure parce que
même s'il ya des centrales qui seront
fermées comme c'est le cas en allemagne
il n'ya pas d'empressement des
compagnies électriques si vous voulez la
démanteler
et puis les procédures réglementaires
sont longues entre le moment où la
décision est prise d'arrêter la centrale
et les autorisations pour le
démantèlement qui en fait fixe
l'objectif du démantèlement il s'écoule
parfois plusieurs années c'est bien
normal
dernier point qui est important à
prendre en compte par exemple pour nos
collègues allemands cesser les activités
devant tellement seront aussi une façon
pour ces entreprises de résoudre la
problématique sociale liée à l'arrêt des
centrales en priorité donc pas
nécessairement beaucoup d'emplois pour
nous alors après je les nouvelles unités
dans l'équipe d' areva vont arriver
encore une fois c'est une entreprise qui
travaille qui construit de nouveaux
réacteurs mais qui aussi participent à
la maintenance des réacteurs existants
et à la fourniture de combustible
nous notons que le marché continue à se
développer l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie indiquent une augmentation de
la capacité nucléaire dans le monde de
l'ordre de 50% d'ici 2030
voilà donc qui maintiendra à peu près le
nucléaire au même niveau de 12 à 13% de
la production d'électricité au niveau
mondial et donc nous participons
l'apport d'areva et la porte d'edf c'est
que nous faisons ce développement avec
les plus hauts standards de sûreté avec
les technologies ip r et atmea qui de ce
point de vue là pour ont été conçus dans
cet objectif même si ça a un coût
supérieur
et même si parfois le fait de promouvoir
cette technologie nous met en difficulté
sur le plan concurrentiel ça a été le
cas très clairement aux émirats arabes
unis
alors je ne partage pas vous m'en
excuser votre approche sur la
l'opposition qui aurait entre
productivité et sécurité mon expérience
de l'industrie c'est que en général plus
on travaille efficacement mieux ça se
passe et ça se passe aussi en matière de
sûreté
donc le plan d'action d'areva c'est un
plan d'action qui a cinq piliers la
sûreté et sécurité
la satisfaction des clients la
performance économique l'innovation et
le développement des ressources humaines
et c'est un développement harmonieux
entre ces différents objectifs
il dans l'entreprise la sûreté est
évidemment un élément absolue une
priorité absolue toutes réunions de
direction à quelques niveaux que ce soit
commence par l'examen des sujets de
sûreté et dans les investissements qui
ont été certes diminué pour le groupe
areva au niveau global les
investissements de sûreté n'ont pas été
diminué ils ont été augmentés
et puis enfin burban comme vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président c'est le
sujet de l'andra plus que le sujet
d'areva mais nous sommes évidemment
intéressé en tant qu' en tant que
producteur de déchets moi je ne partage
pas tout à fait votre sentiment je pense
que c'est un projet qui a fait l'objet
de jets participé en tant que jeune
fonctionnaire aux premières recherches
de sites dans les années 80 dans la
bresse je pense que quand même beaucoup
a été fait depuis en matière d où il y
avait à l'époque et plusieurs sites mais
aussi la bresse je pense que beaucoup a
été fait grâce à l'encadrement
législatif de cette activité et que
l'andra a travaillé très progressivement
aussi bien sur le plan de la recherche
et du développement en lien avec nous
que sur le plan de l'information
nécessaire des populations nous notre
ambition maintenant c'est de continuer à
pouvoir apporter notre savoir-faire
évidemment pour le développement de ceux
de ce stockage
voilà excusez moi d'avoir été un peu
longue le président mais c'était à la
taille de la salle veut des questions si
vous permettez nous avons 10 youn et
hier matin monsieur bigot lycéens qui a
manifesté un certain scepticisme par
rapport à l'objectif de 22 soit pendant
de 50% en 2025
d'abord quand on parle de pourcentage
j'aimerais bien savoir sur quel volume
réel on calcule ce pourcentage parce que
tout ce que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
président que j'allais voitures
électriques
les nouvelles technologies etc fait que
le volume de consommation de
l'électricité continuera d'augmenter et
donc
parler de pourcentage est une chose mais
c'est en volume que j'aimerais bien
savoir quelle est la projection qu'on
imagine de la production nécessaire
d'électricité comment on l'assurera
ensuite j'aurai juste un petit pic à
vous en voyez monsieur le président mais
quand vous parlez de démantèlement que
vous avez une expérience nous en tous
les cas dans l'ouest on a une expérience
qui durent un certain temps si j'ose
dire sur l'oedème démantèlement de
brennilis
ça doit faire plus de trente ans qu'elle
est arrêtée que le démantèlement a
commencé je sais pas si la durée du
démantèlement est égale à la durée de
vie des centrales sur la sur la
consommation d'électricité
mais moi je crois que c'est justement si
vous voulez le sujet absolument
absolument centrale qui va être
déterminant pour piloter cette évolution
vers la verse 50% ce qui bon sentiment
personnel si vous voulez c'est qu'il
l'est probablement incorrect accords etc
est-ce que les 50 pour s'annoncer pauvre
2025 correspond aux 75 % en volume
d'aujourd'hui va écouter dans certains
scénarios d'évolution rapide de la
consommation d'électricité oui olam est
donc aujourd'hui la difficulté de la de
calcul de cette évolution de la
consommation d'électricité mais je crois
que vous recevrez monsieur proglio qui a
des visions encore plus correspondant à
l'activité d'edf
je pense que la période récente la
période récente ne permet pas facilement
d'extrapoler dans la période récente
nous avons eu un bon incontestablement
d'abord une un fort ralentissement
économique dans la période récente
n'avons pas encore vu le poids des
nouvelles technologies de l'information
même si ça commence à prendre sa part et
nous n'avons pas encore vu l'impact de
la voiture électrique ou d'un
développement plus systématique de
transport humain je pense aussi que
nous n'avons pas encore intégré la
croissance démographique le
vieillissement des populations peut se
traduire aussi par le développement à
domicile de toute une série de nouveaux
équipements de domotique de suivi de la
santé d'application mécanique
c'est tout ça qui est à mon avis en
germe en ce moment et qui peut se
traduire par des évolutions
significatives de la consommation
d'électrité production ce qui ne veut
pas dire encore une fois que qu'il ne
faut pas en parallèle faire tout ce
qu'il faut faire pour réduire les
consommations d'électricité dans
d'autres domaines
donc dans des scénarios de forte
croissance de la consommation
d'électricité
eh bien vous le 50% se fait
mécaniquement par et donc la capacité
relativement à la capacité relativement
constante
je crois que ce qui me paraît très
pragmatique dans le projet de loi est ce
que le gouvernement à mettre en place
c'est justement de mettre en place ce
pilotage qui il faut bien reconnaître
avait un peu disparu de nos pratiques et
avoir régulièrement un éclairage
stratégique sur justement une
actualisation des prévisions
comment ça va se traduire en termes de
moyens des moyens arrêter des moyens
nouveaux à construire ça me paraît être
un élément extrêmement important en tout
cas dont nous industriels nous sommes
demandeurs pour planifier nos activités
ce jeu je transmettrai la question à
monsieur proglio
oui simplement quelle est votre
peut-être votre comment paris sur la
réussite du sommet de 2015 c'est ce que
vous espérez une prise de conscience de
des différents pays sur la diminution de
production de co2 c'est pas neutres par
rapport au nucléaire vous avez évoqué la
part de co2 que que fait la france par
rapport à d'autres pays
est-ce que ce sommet aura une réussite
au niveau de la prise de conscience au
niveau international de la priorité sur
le climat énergie à faire moi je veux
partager avec vous mon expérience qui
est limitée au monde des énergéticiens
que je fréquente
moi je suis quand même très frappé de
voir que il n'ya pas un énergéticien il
n'y a pas une compagnie électrique
aujourd'hui qui lorsqu'elle réfléchir au
long terme
elle intègre la nécessité de réduire les
émissions de co2 france et peut-être
qu'il ya vous l'avez vu récemment avec
les déclarations du président obama aux
états unis et une politique maintenant
beaucoup plus affichées vous le voyez
aussi en chine avec lors de la réunion
de la dernière réunion du congrès du
parti communiste chinois
des propos extrêmement offensif du
premier ministre chinois sur le thème de
la lutte contre la pollution avec les
dépollutions qui ont atteint des niveaux
maintenant très très très important
alors il est évident que ya pas qu une
réponse on en connaît la palette de
réponses les économies d'énergie le
nucléaire doit être considérée comme une
réponse et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'une des premières étapes c'est que
dans cette stratégie et de diminution
des émissions de co2 iqu d'abord au
niveau européen
je crois qu'il faut qu' il ya une
réaffirmation de l'existence de
plusieurs technologies capables de
contribuer alors que peut-être que
jusqu'à présent la politique européenne
a été essentiellement dans un discours
sur la promotion des renouvelables et
qu'il faut continuer bien sûr mais
prendre le moment faut-il aussi rappeler
les mérites du nucléaire d'un nucléaire
sûr bien sûr pour contribuer à sa voix
pour courcelles
le pdg d'areva il était entendu par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
économiques